you may have watched it in the olympics
and now maybe you want to try it believe
it or not the sport of curling is a
pretty big deal here in the desert this
is curl vegas they offer opportunities
for everyone to try the sport and if you
like it you can stick around and join a
friendly league the group slides stones
at the las vegas ice center on west
flamingo but eventually hopes to have
its own building to call home vegas curl
operates year round so it's really a
perfect place to cool off from the vegas
heat in the summer
the main thing about curling is it's a
lot of fun
uh and it's a great sport that you can
learn easily
and then you can play the rest of your
life it's the friendliest sport
and we love talking about it and
obviously every four years everybody
comes out and wants to know what the
heck we're doing throwing chunks of
granite down some ice
now while everyone is invited to come on
come on out give it a try and just know
there's a waiting list right now but you
can still sign up and find out how you
can help curl vegas as they pursue their
own building by heading to our website
at 8newsnow.com